هذا وافاد مراسل الجزيره ان عائلات الاسرى
المحتجزين في غزه طالبت بعقد اجتماع عاجل
مع مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي وكانت عائلات
الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه
اغلقت الشارع الرئيسي المؤدي الى وزاره
الدفاع في تل ابيب تزامنا مع اجتماع اعضاء
مجلس الحرب رافعين لافته ضخمه تطالب
بابرام صفقه تبادل اسرى من جانب اخر تظاهر
مئات الاسرائيليين اليمينيين بالقرب من
محكمه العدل العليا في مدينه القدس من اجل
الضغط على الحكومه الاسرائيليه لمواصله
الحرب على غزه وتحقيق اهداف الحرب التي
اعلنتها الحكومه معنا من تل ابيب مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام الياس ماذا عن هذه
الدعوه من قبل عائلات الاسرى باجتماع عاجل
مع مجلس الحرب وما ارتباط هذه الدعوه بما
جرى في اجتماع ليله
البارحه نعم هذه الدعوه على قدر كبير من
الاهميه ذلك انها تعكس الهواجس التي تعتري
عائلات الاسرى الاسرائليين المحتجزين داخل
قطاع غزه وربما اعتبارهم بان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المجلس الوزاري المصغر ومجلس
الحرم لم يحسم موقف اسرائيل فيما يتعلق
بصفقه لتبادل الاسرى وثمت شعور لدى
العائلات بان بنيامين نتنياهو يريد ان
يبعد هذه الصفقه والاستمرار في الحرب ل
اهداف سياسيه تتعلق بتركيبه حكومته
اليمينيه الضيقه الاساسيه بدون حكومه
الطوارئ وان بنيامين نتنياهو لا يسعى
لتحقيق هذه الصفقه اي هذه الرساله جاءت
بعد ان كشفت القناه الثانيه ع الاسرائيليه
ليله امس ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه رفضت
افاده بعثه اسرائيليه الى القاهره من اجل
الاستمرار في التباحث والتفاوض بشان رد
حركه حماس على مقترحات في قمه باريس ورغم
ان هنالك بعض المصادر الان التي بدات
تتحدث عن ان اسرائيل ربما ترسل وفدا من
المساد الى القاهره مطلع الاسبوع المقبل
تحديدا يوم الاحد لكن اسرائيل قالت بانها
لا تريد ان توفد هذا الوفد في هذه المرحله
قبل ان تتخذ قرارا او تناقش رد حماس في
مجلس الحرب وفي المجلس
الوزاري المصغر ولان اسرائيل عمليا عبرت
عن موقفها ربما الرافض لكن ليس العلني
والواضح لما قدمته حركه حماس من مقترحات
هذا يغضب عائلات الاسراء وهم يعتبرون ان
ذلك يبعد الحل ويبعد الصفقه اكثر
ويبقي الاسرى في حاله معاناه مستمره دون
تحقيق اي تقدم من ناحيه اخرى من الواضح
بان انتهاء اجتماع مجلس الحرب وانتهاء
اجتماع مجلس المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون
السياسيه والامنيه في اسرائيل بدون ات
اتخاذ قرار او على الاقل بدون الاعلان عن
اتخاذ قرار كما توقعنا يوم امس هذا يعني
بان اسرائيل لا توصد الباب نهائيا على
مزيد من المفاوضات وعلى مزيد من الحوار من
اجل ربما الالتقاء في وسط الطريق وربما
التوصل الى صفقه لتبادل الاسرى ان لم تكن
شامله بما قدمته حركه حماس من مقترحات
انما ربما على على مراحل لذلك انتهاء
اجتماع المجلس الوزاري المصغر ومجلس الحرب
دون اتخاذ قرار هذا هو امر في غايه
الاهميه وهو يعكس بان اسرائيل لم تقل لا
لكنها ما زالت مستعده للتفاوض ولنش
وللحوار وهذا الحوار ربما كما اشرت يبدا
عبر الوفد الذي يمكن ان تفده الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مطلع الاسبوع ال المقبل من
ناحيه اخرى اجتماع المجلس الوزاري المصغر
واجتماع المجلس الحربي كشف عن عمق
الخلافات الحقيقيه والكبيره بين بنيامين
نتنياهو من ناحيه وبين شركائه الجدد في
مجلس الحرب وهما بيني جانس والوزير جادي
ايزنكوت على اعتبار ان بيني جانس يميل
الان الى اعطاء الاولويه اولا و قبل كل
شيء الى اتمام صفقه للاسرى فيما مازال
بنيامين نتنياهو يتمسك بمساله النصر
الساحق على حركه حماس والقضاء على قدرتها
العسكريه والمدنيه وهذا ربما اهم الخ الذي
كان في داخل مجلس الحرب في اجتماع ليله
امس بنت الاب الياس كرام شكرا جزيلا لك